hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll
probably everyone listening has heard
the phrase a theory of everything right
the origins of this phrase are actually
a little bit murky you know it's not
such a weird collection of words that it
hadn't appeared in the literature a long
time ago you know people have talked
about the idea of a Theory of Everything
But the context in which we currently
usually talk about it is either super
string theory in physics or some other
competitor to Super String Theory as far
as I can tell that coinage came from
John Ellis who is a theorist at CERN uh
he wrote a little article in the early
days of the super string Revolution
1980s called the super string a theory
of everything or of nothing so it wasn't
completely triumphant right he was
actually talking about whether or not
this possibly could be a theory of
everything it was immediately pointed
out by non-physicists and even some
physicists that the idea of a theory of
everything in this sense is actually
very very restricted to a certain
reductionistic way of looking at the
fundamental constituents of nature the
idea being that nevertheless those
fundamental constituents make up
everything else but there's no sense in
which that idea of a theory of
everything would be the final theory
that we ever need in science right
because we do have higher level emerging
things we have biological organisms we
have economies and societ ities and we
have people and psychology all this
stuff right that is certainly not
covered not to mention easy questions
about astrophysics or chemistry or so
forth so the root from that kind of
Theory of Everything to many other
scientific questions is a complicated
one therefore we still have room for
other theories of large grandiose scope
and today's guest is Michael Muk Krishna
who has a book coming out called a
theory of everyone one that's an
intentional play on words from The
Theory of Everything idea the subtitle
is the new science of who we are how we
got here and where we're going obviously
a kind of an ambitious book trying to
synthesize many kinds of ideas Michael
is uh at the London School of Economics
he's sort of I think his his official
title is a professor of economic
psychology so there's both economics in
there and psychology he's actually
collaborated with some of our previous
mindscape guests Joe Henrik and um
Edward slingerland so he thinks about
the grand scope of human history and how
we how we are influenced by biology and
evolution cultural Evolution how we pass
down ideas from generation to generation
and you know a big thing as as he'll say
in the episode a big thing for him is
the fact that human beings unlike other
animals do have this sort of distributed
cultural knowledge that we can pass down
human beings have schools right have an
educational system in a way that other
animals don't other animals do teach
their young some of them do you know I
don't know Lions I am told teach their
cubs to hunt by you know pretending to
be in pain when their cubs bite them a
little bit right so they're teaching
them like oh yes that's the right thing
you should do but they don't have a
curriculum they don't have a syllabus
they don't have it quite as organized
and systematized as human beings do so
that plays a large role in the
exceptionalism of human beings and of
course it's tied to other capacities our
brains our languages things like that so
we'll talk about all of that but then
Michael wants to go much further he
talks about not only economics but the
technological side of Economics the
importance of different ways we have of
harnessing energy from you know just
burning wood to burning fossil fuels to
solar energy and how these allow for
expansions of the economy and therefore
of human opportunity in a very uh clear
way and then he brings it back or brings
it down I should say to the current ERA
our political polarization um our
stagnation of innovation if that's true
and what we can do about it how we can
do better there are parts of this long
elaborate story that I am 100% on board
with other parts that I will wait to see
let's put it that way not 100% but I'm
open to it I you know I think it's
fascinating stuff and uh Michael's very
clear and very well educated on a whole
bunch of things so I think it's a very
good listen with that in mind let's
[Music]
go
Michael M Krishna welcome to the
mindscape podcast thanks for having me
Sean so you've written what sounds to
the average reader of titles like an
ambitious book it's called a theory of
everyone and I like I like that you're
kind of making fun of the physicist
there it is it is a you know it's a
modest title it could have been a theory
of everything right yeah exactly just
people yeah no it's a it's a play on a
theory of everything of course but um I
mean the the title the title hints at
the the central claim of the book which
is that you know we are so I'm sure your
listeners know already but you know the
theory of everything in physics is this
Grand unifying Theory you know uh
general relativity meets quantum
mechanics whatever um the idea or the
the central premise of the book is that
we have reached this point in the human
and social sciences where we have this
overarching theoretical framework that
unifies things that make sense of an
otherwise chaotic and confusing world
and turns it into a real science as so
you know I tell the story of how this
happened in the more mature Sciences to
illustrate how this has happened for the
human and social
sciences um so you know you know like in
physics right uh we used to think that
Thor was banging his hammer and the
physical world was a result of
capricious gods and then you know folks
like Newton and Maxwell and Einstein
come along and they write down equations
I mean Maxwell's crazy right at the time
of like whale oil and horse carriages
he's writing down equations for like
maget amazing
um but suddenly like the world is less
chaotic and confusing we know like the
weather is still difficult to predict
actually but we know that it's not
caused by capricious Gods it's it's
caused by these rules we have the rules
and once we have those we can also turn
them into Technologies right like we can
eventually land a you know a spacecraft
on an asteroid um and the same thing
happened to to chemistry now Newton's
not a dumb guy as we just said but he's
he's trying to turn lead into gold yeah
and again it's not because he's a dumb
guy it's because he doesn't he doesn't
understand like Collision theory he
doesn't know the world is made up of
elements that fit into into a periodic
table but once you have a periodic table
you know um then Alchemy becomes
chemistry so uh you can do stuff before
you have a periodic table like we got to
gunpowder for example but uh you know
why is it that when you pour this acid
on a metal you're you're creating this
gas it's bubbling away like what's
happening there right and can we turn
Len into gold maybe it seems like
another chemical reaction but once you
have a perodic table you can be like yes
we can make gunpowder it's like okay yes
we know what's going on here uh but no
we can't learn turn lead into gold those
are different elements the world is less
chaotic and confusing and eventually you
you make your way not only to to
chemistry like you know turning uh oil
into into Plastics or whatever but even
you know eventually to things like
protein folding um and of course this
happened in biology too right so um it
was a chaotic and confusing World why do
some animals have live BS and others lay
eggs and why does the peacock have this
giant elaborate tale and the pen doesn't
um and then along comes uh Darwin and
later on the modern synthesis with you
know Fischer and Wright and Hamilton and
so on and suddenly the world is less
chaotic and confusing it's still
difficult to predict the trajectory of
species or the behavior of ecologies but
if you're trying to do that without the
rules that underly the system you're
running blind right so yeah in other
words what I hear is that this
underlying theoretical perspective on
what's going on can be helpful at a
higher practical level and let me guess
you want to extend this to human beings
exactly I mean the claim I make it's not
that like I have extended to human
beings but actually we are in the midst
of a revolution on the scale of of
Newton and Maxwell and Einstein and the
scale of the periodic table and the
scale of Darwin and the modern synthesis
that is we know the rules we know why
humans are different to other animals we
know the rules by which humans acquire
and synthesize information we know the
rules by which society are changing over
time and that should allow us to build
the equivalent of Technologies like do a
better job of public policy for example
by applying that so part one of the book
is kind of laying out that theory of
everyone that theory of human behavior
and then part two is like okay well take
me at face value and assume that I'm
correct about what I'm saying here's
what this means about inequality and
Innovation and how we design the
internet and you know what the future of
Education should look like and how we
get past uh energy transition and so on
and how many pages is this book like
5,000 like 480 Pages or something you
know I mean I lean heavily it is it is a
book for the public so I you know what I
try to stay away from like you'll read
some Behavior books and it's like in
this study we showed XYZ I mean the
studies are there but what I really what
I'm really trying to say is like there's
a tapestry there's a world that
everything is connected up it's like
once I explain the periodic table to you
everything makes a lot more sense and so
I Rely heavily on like let me explain it
to you so you can check it against your
own life like you should have new
insights um that that allow you to see
the world as you never saw it before and
once you see it you can't unsee it so
maybe a good starting point then is the
classic question of what makes human
beings so special what makes us
different than the rest of our animal
cousins even though we're actually very
similar at the DNA level right yeah so
what humans are a different kind of
animal that have a a third line of
information or a second line of
inheritance and this is really
fundamentally what allowed us to build
the world that we have today so we not
only have a genetic inheritance like
Hardware that we get from our our
parents right uh and we not only have
kind of a lifetime of experience where
we learn things but we have cultural
software that has accumulated over time
and is literally running on our brains
allowing us to think new thoughts see
the world in richer new ways and
understand the world as no other species
ever has and that cultural line isn't
just learn it is it is evolving it is a
true it's not it's not an analogy to
genetic Evolution it is an extension of
population genetics into the world of
culture we call this cultural Evolution
and it's EV evolving Beyond conscious
awareness so we have a set of behaviors
and values and sometimes technologies
that are not
only the world is not only more
complicated than the smartest among us
could ever recreate but often we don't
really understand why it is that we do
the things we do certainly at an
individual level and sometimes at a
population level like you probably brush
your teeth twice a day and if I ask you
why you'll tell me something about
plaque and tartar or something like that
but you don't really have a good causal
model of that or you know do you you
probably finish your course of
antibiotics right to avoid super bugs
but if and you probably have a causal
explanation for that um but you have an
illusion of explanatory depth that stops
you from checking further like if I were
to say to you it's like obviously Sean
like not every one of those bacteria are
going to die and so surely if not all of
them die surely finishing your course of
antibiotics would have the most
resistant bacteria left that's what
would create super bugs and now you're
like oh wait a minute you know but you
don't have to worry about kind of
antibiotic heill curves or you know the
optimal dosage or anything like
that you have just acquired the
interfaces to interact with the world
you check your emails on a device that
may as well be magic right so the book
is about how that how we evolve to have
that how it is that um we became a
different kind of animal how that
connects everything up and what that
means about how we should study
ourselves and think about our future
right like if you want to understand the
secrets of pivot tables in Excel if you
want to understand how chat GPT works
you don't look inside the CPU and GPU
it's not in the brain it's not in the
Neuroscience actually it's in the
software that's running on that Hardware
so the difference in other words
obviously other kinds of animals and so
forth do have behaviors that are passed
down from Generations but they're not
through learning right I I are there
this it's always a a worry when you talk
about vast generalizations to other
species that there's going to be counter
examples um are there any counter
examples of you know things that are not
genetically encoded but are knowledge
that other yeah animal species pass down
from generation to generation yeah so
this area is called dual inheritance
Theory or Gene culture co-evolution or
the extended evolutionary synthesis and
particularly the extended evolutionary
synthesis does it is about like these
other transmiss like so environments are
transmitted right an earthworm can
inherit the environment created that
more moist environment created by uh its
its ancestors um there's also
information being transmitted uh just
not to the degree that humans do right
so like chimps for example learn from
their mothers and they have traditions
of uh you know wading up leaves into
sponges and sponging up water or using
sticks for tigging termites or whatever
those do seem to be or cracking nuts is
another example of this they're entering
the Stone Age if you like um they do
have have that but humans for reasons I
explained in the book and and maybe I
can say a little bit about that now uh
rely on that social information and
and agree to use that information if you
like we use that information at the
expense of our own everyday experience
and chimps do not do that like I let me
give you an example you're the worst
person to give this example to but I'm
gonna give it to you anyway you'll see
in a moment why that is like if I ask
the average person right or the average
person will swear up and down that we
are on a spheroid rotating around a star
one of many stars in the Milky Way you
know one of many galaxies in the
universe they will swear that up and
down and every day they look outside at
a flat Earth with a sun tracing the sky
from east to west right right now you
might be you know you're among a handful
of people who checked right but for most
people they don't they just believe it
because the smartest people in their
society uh most people in their society
they believe that right um for the
longest time uh
UFOs were like in in the realm of the
flat earth right and maybe they still
should be but at the moment because like
the reliable sources are talking about
what are they called now uaps or
whatever and Aliens now people like wait
is that actually a thing like should I
be reconsidering my model of the world
we should go back to the previous uh
consensus understanding I think there
but but this is interesting because
you're saying two things one of which I
was expecting and one of which is a
little bit uh I I've heard it before but
it's unexpected in this context the
expected thing is you know we we not
only have knowledge we have some kind of
symbolic knowledge right so you know we
can package the knowledge and and spread
it more efficiently between ourselves
and that's obviously a some kind of
phase transition in human behavior that
we can talk about but you're putting
more emphasis than I would have guessed
on our limitations you know which which
I think are very important but it's
interesting to hear in this context you
know we're finite we don't have infinite
ability to do our own research in as in
the current parlons so we kind of have
to rely on our social networks a bit
that's right and so it's actually
because of those limitations that we
ended up with this cultural evolutionary
system it's it's because of those
limitations that we deferred the
calculation the computation The
Innovation to the population level so uh
because we couldn't you know we couldn't
fit all of that in our heads we ended up
like selectively learning and copying
without really
understanding uh that we were able to
surpass it so even there's an experiment
I talk about in the book that really
illustrates this what humans do compared
to other great apes so uh this was an an
experiment done with young children and
young chimps right and so the
experimentor has a box and the box has a
hole on the top and the hole on the side
right and the experimentor takes a stick
and pokes it through the hole in the top
and pokes it through the hole in the
side and uh when they do this they poke
it through the hole in the side they uh
they get a piece of fruit which The
Chimps love uh and they get a sticker
which the kids love so the experiment
pokes a ho through the top pokes a ho
through the side you know hands it to
the chimp what does the chimp do pokes a
hole through the top pokes a hole
through the side all right experiment to
pokes a hole through the top pokes a
hole through the side hands it to the
child what does the child do pokes a
hole through the top pokes the hole
through the side okay now in the key
variation in the treatment you have the
same box but it's no longer a black box
it's transparent you can see into it
okay and you realize that that first
action doesn't do anything there's
actually like a ceiling or a floor you
know where that just hitting that it's
to retrieve the fruit and the sticker
you just need the second action okay but
again the experiment takes a stick pokes
a hole through the top pokes a hole
through the side hands it to the chimp
now if you've ever watched like a chimp
you know doing a working memory task or
spinning through Instagram chips are
smart man very good you know so what do
they do ignore that first action go
straight to the second action and they
retrieve their fruit and they're a happy
chimp what does the child do experiment
to pokes a hole through the talk pokes
hole through the side hand it to the
child what does the child do pokes a
hole through the top Pok hole through
the tide so children this you have a
headful of recipes that you don't fully
understand interesting that you've that
you've accumulated in you acquire from
from the you know from the smartest
people since you were a child around you
some of those you've checked some of the
many of those you haven't and if your
life is going well you've never had a
need to check some of the beliefs that
you hold and the behaviors you engage in
but because we we're smart because we're
dumb you know we're smart because we we
ape better than Apes do and because we
are willing to defer to that body of
information
culture we don't sit naked in the rain
like they do they want to figure
everything out from first principles
they want to understand it before they
do it and so they you know they're stuck
they're stuck at at a particular limit
by their brains that's a wonderful
example I love that experiment because
the cynic might have said see the
children human children not as smart as
The Chimps because they can't figure it
out but your spin on it is whether or
not they're smarter they're relying on a
whole thing that The Chimps don't have
access to the sort of collective
knowledge that gets us through the
complicated social environment we're in
that's that's right but you see that
Collective knowledge isn't just about
kind of behaviors and beliefs it's also
about mental tools like literal upgrades
to our cultural software for thinking
and we know some of this through uh
history thanks to history which is the
cultural fossil record if you like right
so if you take something like numeracy
right like uh some small scale societies
still count one two three and then many
and our ancestors probably counted like
that too right um we were able to get
further using a metaphor for so uh many
societies would use Stones you know
think calcium calculus uh you know maybe
Stones pressed into clay so you've got
notches as well or you know cut into
wood many societies use uh body parts so
we have a decimal system which is super
annoying to be honest it doesn't
translate well to Binary uh it's the
worst of all systems you know um and
other societies use fangi so they count
12 with their with their thumb the
finger bones uh and various other body
parts right I wish we'd landed on 16 but
here we are yeah um you know and so as a
result of this we now had a metaphor for
thinking that we no longer had to use we
just like store it in our heads
represent it in our heads and now we
could count the natural numbers above
one but stones and you know fingers and
whatever they don't make zero obvious
because zero Stones is nothing and
nothing is well it's nothing and so it
took centuries before zero was
recognized as a number and centuries it
was really the 17th 18th century the
negative numbers became more obvious and
again it became it was an upgrade thanks
to a the number line so we moved away
from objects to position right and you
know there's this quote I I have in the
book from a British mathematician
Francis mes re and he's something like
you know negative numbers darken the
very fabric of reality it's like way
melodramatic right and he's right but
once you have a number line it's simple
enough that you can teach it to young
children which is what we do yeah but
it's given us a new ability because
obviously once you can count you can
count to do anything and then the number
line itself gets extended right so it's
like what if you have uh another number
line that is you know orthogonal to the
other one it's like oh a complex plane
emerges right um and so you don't you
don't you can't see this because we live
in a bubble a very big bubble so I don't
mean like you and I you know uh in our
Ivory Towers you know I don't mean like
Coastal Elites and Rural small town I
mean we're all every person We Ever Meet
went through education through school
and school has become since the
Industrial Revolution the primary means
by which we download a cultural package
to the Next Generation because we are a
species that relies on socially
transmitted information you every child
has to catch up on the last several
thousand years of human history and we
try to do it more efficiently because if
we lose that link we literally become
Dumber we literally lose lose a bunch of
Technology right we have to transmit
that every generation but as a result of
that many of the things that we think of
as being human are in fact endowed by us
by accumulated cultural knowledge and
you can't get it by measuring it so the
Stroop test I don't know if you've ever
SE SE the strep test basically you've
got words the color words and they're
written in the color like red written in
red blue written blue I do know what
you're talking about or matched right
and you ask people don't say don't read
the word just say the color so you know
say even though it says red it's written
in blue so say blue and people struggle
reading has become an instinct that
overrides color perception now imagine
you know a psychologist from Venus you
know uh like the Anthropologist from
Mars a psychologist from Venus comes
down and studies these crazy Apes on you
know on the planet and and they give
them the strep test and they're like oh
it appears that humans have an innate
ability to read uh but no innate ability
or it overrides any kind of color
perception which would be wrong of
course right yeah but because this this
these culturally endowed skills have
become part of our thinking they're and
they're ubiquitous at this point you
can't measure it you know all of
experimental psychology all of uh even
IQ tests were developed after the Advent
of of of treny laws and and compulsory
formal education
so even something like the ability to
reason so I talk about some of my own
work right um so Alexander Lua we were
replicating some of his work so Lura
goes out to usbekistan he wants to
understand how education is changing
people's psychology and he uses ifp then
Q reasoning okay so he this is actually
one of his questions he says where it
snows the Bears are white in Nova Zia it
snows what color are the Bears now you
you didn't say it but you're thinking
white uh you know like the USCS with
education white uh my six-year-old white
you know but what happened to the to the
USCS who didn't have education how do
they answer they're like um I think
probably Brown I've seen a brown bear on
you're like what listen to what I'm
saying and you're like well I don't know
what color the Bears are I haven't been
to Nova zimia so it's not that humans
can't reason of course we can right but
it's a grounded cultural reality based
reasoning and it becomes an ability and
a hypothetical ability to reason through
our education system and then the whole
world becomes more complex right like a
new Baseline is achieved so if you you
know if you think about uh TV shows
right like think of like wham bam Batman
from the 1960s versus like the dark
knight from the from the early naughties
right like even the most low brow
television has more convoluted
storylines more characters than you know
what our parents and grandparents
watched right so that is the that is
that is the central premise and so the
book is all about well how does that
software get written and how do we write
better software for the future because
although IQ test results have been going
up they have now stagnated and so have
our schools let me ask the sort of
chicken and egg problem here because
when we talk about human exceptionalism
there's a whole bunch of things that
happen and maybe they're all related
there was some kind of phase transition
right like some people will emphasize
language and symbolic manipulation of
information some people I had Adam bully
on the podcast who is a part of a group
that likes mental time travel the
ability to hypothesize the future and
speak counterfactually as something that
is uniquely human and you're you know
like other people emphasizing this
communal aspect the sort of uh
offloading certain cognitive tasks to
the collective which came first is there
some causality there or is it a package
deal absolutely so actually the book is
about tackles this very problem so you
know people who uh people who posit
things like so I know Adam you know and
I know the language people I'm not sure
who you spoke to but people who posit
language as an explanation are wrong
because language is part of the package
of humans it doesn't explain anything
because you you know in in in
evolutionary biology you have a startup
problem right so let's say I'm the first
person with like some genes for language
well that's useless because nobody else
speaks you know so like you've got a
you've got a startup problem and
language only works if you've got
something worth
transmitting so fair enough so language
isn't an explanation and a lot of the
other features of our of our cognition
are also this part of this package so
you know the story The here's what
here's what a mix of kind of the models
and evidence and what you can kind of
piece together tells us okay so the
first thing that happened was that um
there was a transition across the animal
kingdom but certainly for humans because
of our generation length toward relying
on social information and it is it is if
you look at the the models and
population genetics these are the models
where you can Branch off into a world of
social learning so if you when when the
environment is highly
stable then genes do the best job of
adapting to that environment so even
among humans right skin color is a
genetic adaptation that is well
predicted by latitude because of UV
radiation you don't want so much UV
radiation that you get cancer yeah but
you don't want so little that you have
vitamin D deficiency which also leads to
Cancers and other diseases right but the
time scale is very long for those
adaptations to happen so a stable
environment is where it works they're
fairly long but they happen right for
for for for the human generation length
which is not you know last several
thousand years 100 thousand years right
um it's not sometimes if there's if
selection is strong enough it can be
quite fast okay and if if there's
variation in the population um and so so
by the way you know remember like humans
like part of this puzzle is that humans
when most animals encounter a new
environment they're forced to
genetically adapt and we did a little
bit like human skin color right but you
know like more more fat for the Arctic
more uh you know proteins to process the
local plants we TR we as hunter
gatherers before you know physics
chemistry biology psychology all of this
stuff and even before agriculture we
marched across the
planet and we figured it out in each
stage you know we figured out how to
process the proteins using you know like
new tech new techniques and so that we
could eat them you know we we we we
didn't um get much more fat and fur we
hunted the local animals and avoided
prey and wore sometimes the Predators
you know uh skins as our own right
so this is what we need to explain this
is what we need to explain so gen do a
great job if if the environment is
highly stable if the environment is
highly
unstable then genes are not a good
solution because you know today the red
berries are edible tomorrow it's the the
blueberries and the water is here the
water is there whatever right instead
Evolution has to rely on trial and error
learning across the lifespan to figure
it out you got to have a big brain to do
that and you got to do a lot of trial
and error and it's really
inefficient and so these key models
developed by uh you know mostly by Roy
um Rob Boyd and Pete Richardson and also
by you know uh Cav Schwartz and Mark
Feldman over at Stanford there's an
intermediate zone of environmental
variability where it is matched to
generation length such that your parents
and grandparents have some knowledge
worth paying attention to and it is it
is at this point that we begin to rely
on the information they have so imagine
something like a cyclical drought yeah
maybe you know You' you've never
experienced one the lag is too long
right uh maybe a parents either but
Grandma remembers that when she was a
child there was a drought and they went
left of the forest past the mountain and
you know she leads her tribe to safely
and you know I was I was recently um uh
talking to an she's like that actually
happens you know oh yeah you know this
is this is a real thing Kim Hill you
know was telling me you know from his
group y um so so now in this zone so
this was a nice model developed in the
1980s right 1981 1985 these models were
developed uh and everyone was like oh
that's cool that yeah maybe that's what
happened and what happened was in the
late 90s and early 2000s we actually got
ice core data so we could see climatic
variation what did we find massive
amounts of variation followed by a
moderate Zone as you know exactly the
moment when humans evolve now you should
have to you should pause for a second be
like well wait a minute all those
animals surely they all experience right
there is a there is a link to there is a
link to generation length for the first
half but you also need something else to
kick this thing off you got this
bootstrap problem okay so I suspect uh
you know in the book this is going a
little we don't have a model of this you
know by the way you know theories only
become theories if you can write them
down
fair so you know this what I just said
we've got good models for good good
empirical evidence uh what I'm about to
say we don't have as good models except
when it comes to brain Evolution which
is some of my own work um so I suspect
bipedalism actually did a lot for us
okay and the reason for that so we were
we probably bipedal for completely
separate reasons right this is kind of
an early adaptation and by being bipedal
it did two things one it freed our hands
for you for making tools and carrying
them around right so you can invest in
that stone axe because you can carry it
to the next location and use it again
whereas if you're a quadrupedal ape like
a chimp or a orangutang or gorilla or
whatever like you don't want to carry
this big ass rock around so you don't
you have to reuse it so it cheapened the
cost of tools the second thing that it
did is what I'm doing with you right now
that unfortunately audio listeners can't
see which is talking with my hands right
not just Italians we all do it I saw you
do it you know we talk with our hands
and so that opened up a new modality for
communicating with so now now we can
begin to solve that language problem
which as I said is not an explanation
it's part of that package so imagine I
should say more so information begins to
accumulate because cultural Evolution
becomes a second line of inheritance and
that happens because of what I described
there so for any evolutionary system
needs three
ingredients variation like diversity
easy to solve for culture people do all
kinds of things for all kinds of reasons
different information different
personalities
whatever transmission so you need
reliable you don't want too much
information to be lost during the
transmission process so for uh for for
genes of course it's because genes are
are are not mutating at a very high rate
and you need variation reduction and if
you want it to be adaptive you need
selection where more of the good stuff
sticks around and less of the bad stuff
right Y and if if you meet those
criteria you have an evolutionary system
it's how genetic algorithms work right
um so genes we know how that works for
culture I just gave you the transmission
we copy without understanding and so we
don't lose too much information and we
do it selectively we copy people who are
more successful we copy people who other
people are copying we copy people who
are experts you know we we have a we
have a psychology that leads us to for
example if a celebrity says I'm drinking
this drink you're like I want that drink
we do it instinctively why it's got
nothing to do with their success right
but other PE you know but we don't know
it's a black box I don't know why you
know uh Beyonce is such a great singer
so I'm just gonna I'm gonna wear her
perfume and I'm gonna dress like her we
G do everything because you know in if
I'm trying to copy the best hunter maybe
it's because of the shoes he wears or
you know his weapons or where he goes
hunting but equally it's because of his
kickass beard or fact that he shaves his
head or the gods he worships so little
Hunter copies everything about them now
if you have that system you've already
deferred to the population level and
information begins to accumulate okay
now we have evidence for early
accumulation of information because um
one of the best pieces of evidence from
in my view that this is absolutely why
humans evolved is the the fact that we
rely on cooked food our Jaws are too too
weak for chewing like a gorilla on
leaves all day and our guts are too
short to process that food anyway even
if we could right so that means we were
cooking food we had fire now I don't
know if you've ever tried to light a
fire but it's hard man it's it's hard
right even once you're taught it's hard
right um and so like that meant that we
needed fire to survive and we don't have
genes for it it's got to have been
culturally transmitted you couldn't have
figured it out so that's a very early
very early bit of information and maybe
the stone tools too and probably before
the stone tools the bone tools and the
wooden tools that didn't survive the
passage of time when you say very early
what years are we guessing so uh we're
talking like millions of years uh
millions of years ago one and a half
yeah yeah so this is like very early on
so before like modern humans yeah and we
have evidence for this right like we
have little bits of evidence for for and
so that meant while we were bipedal we
had information worth
transmitting right and so that means you
can get what's called a baldwinian
process in evolution so a baldwinian
process is one where you can get to a
place through learning but if you can
get there through genes more efficiently
those genes can be
selected so in this case I can I there
is a bunch of gestures I can give you so
you can build the tool or light the fire
or know that you know I can I can have
guttural utterances and I can wave my
hands in a particular way and you can
learn that that means just through you
know reinforcement learning figure out
what I'm talking about but now if you
have cognitive changes that allow you to
acquire that bit of language that bit
you can do it more efficiently and that
means the next Generation you can do a
little bit more and a little bit more
and a little bit more now you have the
ratchet to get up in the presence of an
accumulating body of knowledge you see
where I'm going yeah I do and go ahead
keep going there yeah so so you have you
have you you can begin to accumulate
this knowledge right and so some of the
genetic changes by the way like made us
more susceptible to choking so as I say
in the book we were literally dying to
speak to one another you know um and and
so you know and so we had so this did a
few things so one now we had all this
knowledge we had language begin to
evolve language continues to evolve by
the way so for example it becomes more
efficient uh some of my research and and
our brains grew so they tripled in size
compared to our last common ancestor you
know five to seven million years ago
with a chimp our brains gr to the point
where if you look at the medical
literature today once you hit about the
85th percentile so doctors used to think
it was like big babies were difficult to
birth turns out it's not big babies big
heads once you hit about the 85th
percentile it hockey sticks up in terms
of emergency cesarians and emergency you
know forceps so basically you need these
so that means for our species like it
was kind of the curse of Eve right like
we had all this knowledge big brain it's
painful and dangerous childb birth for
mother and baby yeah um so so we did
other things we we began to for example
extend our childhoods right so one one
change that that that seems to have
happened for us is we had a self-d
domestication and we became neotonus
which is a easy change for evolution to
make I mean we turned the Magnificent
wolf into a
pole you know so we we neonize dogs into
permanent puppies and the same thing
happened for us we are permanent
youthful Apes able to learn for a very
long time so we had a longer childhood a
longer juvenile period and we created an
adolescence which is the period from
when you could reproduce to when you
actually do which has been growing and
growing as the body of knowledge has
begun to grow it used to be that like a
high school degree was enough to get a
job then it was a high school degree
plus any college degree then a stem
degree then also a master's degree and
an unpaid internship and so and so now
we're actually hitting a new limit so
before the primary selection was on like
being able to give birth to these bigger
heads now it's like about giving birth
at at an older age right yeah um this
all of this completely changed our
Societies in a variety of ways that puts
the whole human package together it's
what created grandmothers it's what
created you know the the difference
between men and women like it created
Dads very unusual among great apes um it
uh yeah I mean the the division of labor
you know the division of information all
of this emerges so it's not what you
know the theory of everyone isn't like
so I make fun of um what I call uh I
love this genre of book by the way uh
the one thing that explains everything
you know the to kind of books you know
it's like let me show you why my little
bit of research that I just love happens
to explain the whole damn world right
yeah um this is this is a toy adjacent
book like to is like an Acron for that
you know it's adjacent right for sure
but I'm not like doing this one thing
like I've got you know I kind of talk
about the role that energy like the big
theme of the book is the role that
energy and particularly excess energy uh
has played in all of life and certainly
in our civilization and I talk about the
fact that there are kind of four laws
and you're going to hate this as a
physicist but I don't mean neonian laws
I mean kind of lenses upon which we can
view the world you know the law of
energy which is fundamentally life is
competing over excess energy the law of
Innovations in efficiency so life is
evolving new ways to use that energy
more efficiently the law of cooperation
that the scale of cooperation is a level
at which the individual unit be they
cells or individuals or you know in a
society or in a or employees in a
business is the level at which the per
person per unit uh return on energy is
not going to be higher in a larger or a
smaller group and the law of evolution
which is that both through genetic and
cultural Evolution and the interaction
between these we find the space of how
to cooperate how to innovate at a
population level and how to how to
unlock new bits of energy which you know
thanks to the fall so fuel Revolution
with the Industrial Revolution we now
live in that world well let's talk about
energy a little bit because the story
that you just painted reminds us of this
idea that history is basically a search
for calories right uh food calories back
in the day and then when we invent
industrial technology we're just we need
even more calories in the sense of of an
energy source and and part of the theme
of your book is how much of a central
organ organizing principle that is for
human history correct yeah that's
exactly right so you know for for us the
the first um this is an ancient thing
you know what you just said about
calories and and I you know I put it in
terms of jewels or Watts like this is
fundamentally what matters you know the
first organisms whenever we turn from
RNA into the first self-replicators or
whatever um sorry other way around you
know the the first self-replicators into
RNA and eventually organisms um the only
energy we had is like the fact that we
got a large Moon which was closer to the
Earth sloshing the water back and forth
over you know the land and the Seas so
you got some gravitational energy there
but some of it the sun falling so we
have the earliest Proto photosynthesis
which was um uh which didn't use any
Oxygen right right and uh then we had a
mutation which uh led to a more
efficient photosynthesis which you know
polluted the world the great oxygenation
event mass mass extinction but there was
also a new opportunity so once we had
photosynthesis turning solar energy into
into chemical energy in the form of like
ATP and little sugar little sugar cubes
basically it meant that other organisms
could begin to find a new niche of not
directly converting the sun into into
organism and moving at plant Pace but
eating other organisms and moving a
little faster right there were like a
little bundle just it's a story of
colonialization actually you know an
energy-rich little corner of Eurasia
creates the largest Empire the world has
ever seen out competing other less
energy less Le less Cooperative
Societies in devastating ways um and so
you know so the same pattern happens
throughout life you got procaryotes
getting eaten by ukar ukar being eaten
by uh multicellular life complex
multicellular life and eventually all
the way to you who is more like an
ecosystem an Amazon rainforest of a
microbiome and you know an interacting
differentiated cells more than you are a
single organism and if you run out of
energy you're going to get defeated by
the lower scales by the bacteria or
you're going to get your stuff stolen
from you by the bigger scale same
pattern across the across everything so
uh for for humans the in terms of our
calories the the first unlocking of
energy was the one I described before
which is fire right uh we it was a
chemical energy technology that allowed
us to pre- digest foods and make them
those calories more bioavailable which
allowed us to grow those brains and
Shrink those guts right occupy a new
Niche the next major Revolution was
agriculture which was a solar technology
right where now rather than expending
all that energy walking around searching
you know hunting and Gathering like
trying to find plants to small animals
or large animals in a group you
domesticate and look after animals and
you you you you grow food more
efficiently it was the law of innovation
if you like and the law of energy and
you grow your population to the point
where you out compete the hunter gather
groups to the margins that are not
suitable to agriculture which is still
where they live today right and those
larger groups are able to innovate more
and you lay the foundations for the
beginnings of cities as kind of massive
nodes of collective intelligence right
this continues and we live in a
malthusian world right of because
because the pattern in this story across
every scale is that when you get this
unlocking you get an era of abundance
and that would have been that first era
of abundance and then because carrying
capacity has gone up the number of
individuals meets that carrying capacity
and you once again enter an era of
scarcity where the per person calories
or energy is lower the the next major
unlocking that is most relevant to us
was the Industrial Revolution which if
you look at any metric of progress the
size of our polies the you know child
survival rates anything you care about
it just shoots up into the sky right and
as in Mars puts it it made a mockery of
all the world's earlier history
Scientific Revolution Black Death
Renaissance blips in anything we care
about and that's because we exploited
stored solar energy in the form of like
Pete turned to Black Rock Coal and you
know uh algae you know whatever turned
to oil and and natural gas right and we
unlocked that in a matter of centuries
we began to burn that down and we using
that excess energy we multiplied
ourselves and our efforts we had another
Agricultural Revolution the Green
Revolution you know Norman borag um
where we synthesize through the habob
Brash process we synthesize fertilizer
with nitrogen in the air and uh you know
natural gas and this allowed us like
four billion people half the population
of alive today thanks to that process
we're literally eating our fossil fuels
we use them to develop new technologies
now here's here's here's where we
transition to you know part two of the
book in which is that the energy return
on investment which is a key metric I
care a lot about um is decreasing so the
excess energy is shrinking and economics
and a lot of what we do we focused on
efficiency because they all developed
long after the Industrial Revolution
right or after the Industrial Revolution
and so if you look at one metric like
oil Discovery and all the metrics look
like this um in 1919 one barrel of oil
found you another thousand barrels okay
so massive return on energy by 1950 one
barrel oil a barrel of oil found you
another 100 and by 2010 one barrel found
you another five
so so the the level of cooperation is
governed by this if you like the space
of the possible created by an energy
ceiling and an efficiency floor and that
is shrinking our ability to innovate new
efficiencies is is decreasing the rate
of that is decreasing and the and the
ceiling is rapidly falling on us and so
our societies all of the fractures are
cracking we're we're falling back to
lower scales of cooperation as a result
of this let's let's actually get out of
this is a question let's pause and dwell
on this because I think this is an
important thing uh okay first let me
just sort of summarize this this point
which I'm going to be very much in favor
of as a physicist that the progress
progress in the sense of just change not
necessarily Improvement of human society
is a story of transitions right it's
more punctuated equilibrium than gradual
Improvement we you know in gradual and
occasional punctuated yeah sure yeah but
the but the idea that we do innovate we
find some new mode for doing something
whether it's producing energy or
technology or whatever and then that giv
gives us space right we can then grow
into that but you're saying that as we
do grow into that as we sort of reach
what might be a new equilibrium we also
because there's less spare excess wealth
in various forms to go around things get
squeezed a little bit our social fabric
gets a little bit harder to uh
maintain that's right so I mean our not
only hases population grown and so that
alone is but that's a good thing for the
most part because it means more
Innovation right like more people more
in so far as everyone is able to access
all of that cultural knowledge and you
know opportunity matches talent and all
of that stuff which as we both know is
an often not always true yeah um but but
yeah the other side of it is simply that
the space itself is shrinking because
not only is abundance turning to
scarcity for the usual reasons but we're
reentering a malthusian world simply
because our excess energy is decreasing
like it doesn't matter how fancy your
gadgets and Technology are if you can't
charge them like our ability to access
energy isn't just like price it's a
proxy for it that's affected by a bunch
of of other things it's literally how
much energy do I need to get some amount
of energy back Ideal World you want a
small energy sector it's like 5% of the
economy at the moment right that's great
but as because it means that the Returns
on that energy allow you to do
everything else that makes life worth it
like traveling on flights across the
planet and you know hanging out with
your friends and eating great food that
requires ingredients drawn from all
around the world all of that stuff
relies on abundant
energy and I I guess I think you're
going to have to convince me of this one
a little bit more because I can imagine
you know the same kind of General story
but then saying well once we reach some
equilibrium uh once we have some steady
flow of energy in and things out then we
can figure out a way to organize our
society that fits in to that equilibrium
you know the moments of change in in a
different telling than what you just
gave the moments of change are the scary
ones where we're not sure what's going
on but once everything is a steady flow
there we might reach a happy equilibrium
but you seem to be saying that's not
empirically what happens that's it's a
very physicist answer Sean no I mean in
biology regardless of our you know
evolutionary Game Theory there are no
equilibrium and the reason for that is
because you know in a world so you know
I tell the story in the beginning of the
book like why I got into this I'm
trained as an engineer you know
originally and I kind of Switched fields
and the reason that I did that is I got
really concerned around CL change and I
got concerned about a lot of I've lived
in a lot of different places like Africa
and New Guinea and things like that and
I was concerned that people don't
understand culture first off and second
climate change we're all focused on
mitigation but as the world changes
we're also gonna have to figure out how
to live in a climate changed world and
some of that we get like carbon capture
and those kinds of Technologies but how
do you deal with a million bangladeshis
underwater coming into India how do you
like not have civilization come apart
what does that mean for uh you know the
Middle East and then for Europe like the
Syrian migration crisis is the first
example of that you know you had climate
change probably induced droughts you
have a bunch of people coming into
cities there's not enough jobs to go
around not enough infrastructure to
support them eventually they start to
you know to and then the geopolitics
kicks in eventually you have a difficult
problem at Europe's store step right
that's what I wanted to to work on so
the the thing is that in a world like
you know I remember watching Al Gore's
documentary in 2007 and I was like Gore
and I I started reading the ipcc reports
I was reading the Pentagon reports and I
was like Gore is absolutely right about
the problem but he's crazy like are we
going to slow the economy to Save the
Planet if we do amazing I'm happy but I
just I just don't believe that because
in a world where every every country is
trying to outcompete every other country
every company is trying to outcompete
every other company and every individual
wants more than their
neighbors you're not going to get this
equilibrium sustainable you know
whatever you're all you're going to do
is encourage a zero some malthusian
world where your success means my loss
because there's a limited pie from which
we are taking stuff unless unless you
somehow equalize everything and people
don't like that so I mean any theory of
change or any theory of society that
requires a complete shift in human
nature and not just constraining in some
way is broken it's it's broken from the
beginning it's broken before you got
there so this is an example there isn't
you know so like ideas like degrowth or
you know like just pure sustainability
and stagnation are dangerous because
they will shove us back into a zero sum
environment is that what it was like
back in the hunter
gatherers yeah so hunter gatherers
really interesting so we have some new
work where we're trying to so Hunter
gathers are oh well some Hunter gather
groups are known for their
egalitarianism right uh they do equalize
right uh if you move to like pastoralist
and chiefdoms you you start to see a bit
more inequality and things like this and
so people sometimes interpret that as
the ancestral state was uh you know was
was an egal humans are by Nature
egalitarian no that is probably an
adaptation to those zero some conditions
where there is weak property rights why
because in a world that is zero sum and
that means your your G G is my loss and
vice
versa if you like you start a pizza
business right pizza and I'm like you
started a pizza business you took a
piece of that limited market I'm got to
like burn your business down or take
from you that's what it incentivizes it
incentivizes destructive competition in
a world that's positive some you start a
pizza business I'm like yo I got to
start my own chain of pizza you know
like obviously the pizza business is
booming very different psychology
productive competition so Huna gathers
in a world of distructive competition
and there's two equilibria that emerge
in the model one they just kill each
other to extinction because of these
destructive Cycles or two they they
manage to flatten but the consequence of
that flattening is a decrease in
productivity because what is the point
if you can't rise higher right it's a
little decrease in production and it is
a kind of stagnation if you like right
that that eventually gets you
outcompeted by the pastoralists by the
agriculturalists by you know the larger
societies that are not engaged in that
and so that's the central problem with I
what I think the solution you're
alluding to well it's not even a
solution I'm just wondering what this
BAS possibilities is but you're you're
pointing out that to put it in the
harshest possible terms inequality can
be a driver of innovation correct and we
and an evolution like life is is
competing now you could get Cycles if
you like you know like Predator prey
model type stuff you know where it's
like you you get a nice bird and the
rabbits go up and you know the hair go
up and then you know the foxes a catch
up and then you get a li you can get
these kind of equilibria emerge but it's
not a it's a malthusian world that most
animals and it we escaped the malthusian
Trap simply because we got a little
boost so the question is so my my view
is that in order to tackle these very
real problems around sustainability
climate change and not destroying
ourselves in our planet we need the next
era of abundance not right you know an
era of scarcity because you know the
countries that are it's first off it's
easier to be nice to people when there's
plenty to go around right and second the
countries that can invest in looking
after their environment and preserving
blocks of land and and wanting to live
in a clean environment of those that are
wealthy enough energy rich enough that
they're not worried about simple things
like food and you know having enough
resources for hospitals and education
and other infrastructure those are the
countries like you know I was in
Australia recently um I'm Australian
citizen actually you know like so I you
know I was I was at the great Barry Reef
I was there as a as a teenager and I
remember like oh my God like I was in
these areas it was like so bleached
right this was in I don't know early
2000s or something and I was back again
last year year and I was astonished I
was talking to people like how did you
manage to restore the reef they have
money they have resources and they care
about it enough because they have the
highest household wealth in the world
and the only country in the world that
has you know positive migration from
America right um so they're able to
invest in it if they want to you do that
in a world of abundance not scarcity so
yeah and and I don't want to disagree
because I don't know enough to be able
to disagree but I'm curious about uh the
possibilities like I said is that that
story you just told is is compatible in
my mind with an equilibrium zero some
game where everybody has that level of
wealth right I mean I haven't quite seen
the connection to inequality and
competition it's it's just exactly what
you said so there is no Baseline right
there's no like now I'm satisfied right
you know like I have enough like
progress and you know and and compet
like we want more we want more than our
neighbors and there's always problems to
be solved and and even if you as a
society even if you as an individual
decide you know what I have enough we as
a society you're going to get out
competed by the mutation cultural or
genetic right where that says actually I
want a little more yeah it's not in
equilibri in other words it's invadable
by that other mutation okay I'll make
I'll make one more stab at utopian
egalitarianism and then then we move on
uh even if we bought the idea that
inequality is is going to happen unless
it's sort of we enfor Force some kind of
rigid uh you know equitability that
everyone is unhappy um C can we imagine
that we're in a world of such abundance
now that we can have some equality some
competition some motivation for
Innovation and yet the worst off people
are still much better off than they are
today in the actual world yeah I mean I
I think the the issue is um so I I kind
of survey the the Energy Technologies
available to us and I really apart from
solar uh if we solve the battery problem
and hydro which is fantastic if you've
got fast rolling Rivers please use them
G Canada you know uh it's really it's
really nuclear uh as having the right
numbers apart from fossil fuels and the
fact that those are decreasing we're in
real trouble and you know there are
there are you you can have a society
that's more redistributive and it comes
at a cost
or look at the top 100 uh European
companies right um they're old you know
very few were you know invent you know
created like this this Century if you
like look at the top 100 American
companies how many of them right Europe
redistributes a lot and so it squashes
you know it's a it's a good like I live
in Europe right I live in the UK
somewhere in between it squashes things
and so productivity is lower production
is lower and so you end up you know with
America doing a lot of the Innovation
and there's a little bit of freew
writing you know where you get to
benefit from all of those drugs and all
of those Technologies you get to use the
iPhone you get to use you know the
internet you get to use all of these
different Technologies but it's being
driven by this American you know uh this
creation of inequality in America driven
like you know so I talk about Silicon
Valley right Silicon Valley is a people
think of it as like a Bastion of success
no man it's a graveyard of failure right
oh yeah and you know and and that's what
America you know America says you do you
everybody go try you can do this too
right it's terrible at an individual
level the Asian model like the you know
Asian tiger mom you know Japan whatever
is you know you don't do you you do me
like you do the you follow the script
and everyone is better off but it leads
to incremental Innovation like you have
to believe in a crowded Market where
everybody also thinks this and most
people still fail that you're gonna make
it yeah and a society that encourages
that in a large enough marketplace with
enough
energy results in finding the few apples
what we call unicorns for a reason right
the apples the Amazon the alphabets the
whatevers right and the graveyard of
failure is forgotten because America is
richer as a result of this and you you
draw good I'm gonna give up on the
Utopia there you know the egalitarian
I'm actually not highly committed I I
would enjoy this actually not highly
committed to it but I I want to learn
but um you then take this picture I know
we've given it very short shrift because
it's a it's a a deep book with a lot of
things going on but you take this
picture of human nature and the
development of History through these
Transitions and getting the energy and
you apply it to current issues that we
have I mean climate change is one of
them of course but also political
polarization I mean what about you know
the growth of populism and
authoritarianism and so forth how do we
understand that through this
lens so I mean the first thing is you
know like ideally you want to predict
you want to explain but then you want to
be able to do something about it I mean
so I see the rise of there are always
fractures that exist in a society right
there are always fractures they are the
uh class divisions ethnic divisions you
know
um Regional divisions there's all these
fr that exist but in a world where
there's plenty to go around people just
Mumble and grubble so you know I have
this analogy imagine the buses buses
coming along right that's the rate of
economic growth and uh people are
waiting for the buses and you know you
you've got some people who like have
special passes the 1% get to the front
of the line first and you've got groups
to like favor their in group and like
they're like come on you can come in
front and you're waiting there but if
the buses are coming every five minutes
you Mumble you Grumble but you put up
with it because you're gonna get a seat
just wait five minutes more but if the
rate of buses slows down when an hour
on a
day it's like driving around a car park
where there's plenty of spaces versus
only one and now some so can I
say that on your podcast go ahead yeah
the someone like tries to take your your
your place right
um it's a very different
psychology so and and it doesn't even
have to be like a reality like the
perception that that is happening the
created perception can create the
reality right or or if you're looking at
if you if you're if we have a
psychologist that's sensitive to rate of
change
right and you feel like things are
slowing down a little bit right that
alone is enough to trigger this those
fractures becoming something more so
then you can have the rise of the right
wing you can you end up with more ethnic
fractures you get political polarization
you get all those fractures becoming
something more and the solution to that
is one if you've got the resources
invest right you can't have a million
people turn up at your door if you don't
have enough food and water and prepare
for those guests right so you need to
invest in infrastructure so that all
already stretched schools you know the
good schools the hospital lines you
people are not waiting and waiting and
now they're annoyed because you're
giving things to newcomers like that's a
recipe for ethnic conflict but if you're
investing and you're like you know
alongside this this new group of people
we're going to put in all this money so
that there's enough space for everyone
that's a good thing and if you don't
have that you need to be investing in
Energy Technologies that allow us to
raise that ceiling so I talk about the
umbrella model of multiculturalism is
really fusing all of these Solutions
into something that would work in a way
that current melting pots or mosaics or
you know umh no no hyphen French models
really just don't so just to try to
rephrase it because I I do think this
resonates with something that I I had
believed for a while uh there one of the
things the major factor that the what
what is the acronym you use that you the
one thing that explains
everything when it comes to uh you know
populism Etc is the idea that people who
are not well off which you might think
are going to go for like leftists who
who want to spread the wealth but they
really are feeling powerless and both in
the sense that their political voices
aren't heard and that their lives are
getting worse right yeah and that then
they that that combination pushes them
toward appealing to a strong figure who
can shake things up yeah yeah look you
know as as I point out in the book I
don't think there's good evidence that
people don't like
inequality what people don't like a
double negative so you're saying that
they're people like an like equality no
I'm not saying that people like equality
or or inequality or whatever what the
people want is fairness yeah okay like
people want the outcomes to be matched
to the input you know like they want a
return like they don't want necessarily
the handout maybe some people do right
but like people want the
opportunity so that what they do that
they're hard work like if they choose to
wake up early and get to the front of
the line at that bus stop they will get
at their seat and when that stops
happening no matter how early they wake
up or or because of where they're born
or who they're born to they just never
get that seat that is the problem that's
when Society starts to come apart and
that's what we need to resolve so you
know in the section on inequality I
differentiate between um you know wealth
creation versus wealth
appropriation wealth appropriation is
rent seeking it's monopolistic Behavior
it's like land you know like holding on
to land for centuries as in the country
I live in you know where you're just
you're just you're just taking you know
a rent on the land providing additional
value right this is why we need like
land value taxes kind of a way out of
this it's is like a huge thing that I
talk about in the book whereas wealth
creation is like you created Apple or
you created you know windows or you
created Amazon yeah you put like a bunch
of high streets and malls out of work
but you made things more efficient that
consumers like and you actually imp you
created wealth in some sense either
through efficiency the law of efficiency
sorry the law of Innovations and
efficiency or because you've you've
found some new energy technology or
something right you've literally created
a new you you've increased the space of
the possible and you are allowed to keep
a part of that space and you are allowed
to make other bets that we hope will
continue to expand the space but the
issue is that uneed intergenerational
transmission of wealth that entrenches
that inequality slowly over time having
the remaining people fight over smaller
and smaller scraps that is when Society
comes apart and that's what we need to
solve so you'd be in favor of larger
estate taxes would be great uh as I
point out in the book that would be
great but it runs up against a few
issues one is uh smart estate planning
uh wealth flight where people take their
money out of the
country and it it also goes against you
know it goes against kind of instincts
about like provisioning for your
children and working harder later in
life it's it would be great what here's
the outcome you want you want to create
a world and that is every generation has
a fairly Fair playing field to start
with so that the best and brightest of
every generation can push forward our
species to where we need to go and over
time things acrew that prevent that
happening so what I actually so there's
a you know there's a there's an Open
Secret within economics where across the
political Spectrum you know people agree
that most taxes are distortionary you
know they affect your behavior negative
ways like your income tax right like if
you are afraid you're going to earn a
little bit more and move into the next
income bracket you're like that marginal
gain is not worth it for me so now it's
distortionary on your productivity your
production um you know sales tax like
I'm not going to buy that because of the
sales tax it's distortionary on Commerce
there's one tax that is
non-distortionary
and there's a moral case for it and it
is fair and it would do away with the
need for the other
taxes you could get rid of income tax
you could get rid of sales tax you get
rid of capital gains tax and you could
still pay for the US Military and
Medicare and you know this country many
more things so that is land value taxes
so the one asset that people own that
they did not create the one asset that
stands above all others is land and I
don't mean like what you do on the land
you shouldn't be taxed for your
buildings or anything anything you do on
the land but the land itself is common
and there's a moral case almost like
slavery where we really need to get rid
of this ability to own land or at the
very least those who take that land
should be taxed uh for you know for that
use of that land for its most and this
does all kinds of things so it's it's
non-distortionary it leads to the most
productive use of that land it solves a
lot of housing issues um and the only
barrier to it that people agree is is
going to require Revolution unless I
guess the middle class realize that
because we all you know I own land you
own land you know like We own land but
what you don't realize is how little you
own relative to you know many others
25,000 Britain who Brits who own half of
the country or you know the 10% of
Americans who own I think 60% of the
country but just to just to point out
this is very radical as a proposal and
there's probably you know U
unanticipated consequences here the
difference between Utopia and you know
and a better world are constraints yeah
and what you point you know they real
constraints on this and so what I what I
suggest you know I suggest Pathways out
of this so the path dependence leads us
into a world like it's hard to rewrite
the Constitution it's hard to like
change the tax code overnight but what
you can do is uh do what for example so
you know last week I was in Estonia
because I want to understand how they
are the top of the pza tables in the
Western World beaten only by a handful
of other handful of East Asian countries
uh and they do it while spending less
per C per student than the rest of the
than the oecd average and certainly less
than the US Canada UK Australia you know
then and they and they have better
outcomes how did they do that hey sorry
explain what these tables are that
you're talking about oh sorry yeah sorry
the the O's pza tables test students
around the world on on mathematics on uh
reading and on science good okay and
Estonia tops that table their students
top the table right uh apart as I said
from a couple a few the Asian countries
how did they do that so I went there to
understand you know I spoke to the
former education Minister I spoke to the
person who founded what was called the
tiger lead foundation so after the fall
of the um well after the Soviet
occupation ended in 1991 only half the
country had a telephone so you know when
Estonia became his own country they were
like okay if we want to LEAP ahead we're
gonna have to do something different
we're not like super wealthy we don't
have like a bunch of resources we just
have our people right that's it we got
to invest in our people and so you know
you can tell you can see how why the
people who who did this thought of it
because of their own experiences but
they decided to really invest in
technology so they created what was
called the tiger leap Foundation where
they overnight gave access to computers
uh you know for every student they
Internet connected to everybody they
trained the teachers and so on right and
they were able to do this because they
have radical
decentralization every school has
autonomy over what they do every
municipality has autonomy and the
central government can't just say let's
do this they have to incentivize so
teachers were incentivized to share
knowledge through this teacher social
network called school life they um gave
them opportunities and incentivized by
sharing that knowledge they increased
their pay they gave them opportunities
to travel to other places to borrow the
best from things from around the world
creating a brand new curriculum and they
tested a bunch of things at a local
level and when it worked it got spread
to the rest of the
country many you know so you know in
this case for example robotics is taught
like they were the first country to
teach Reading Writing arithmetic and now
algorithms to like Elementary School
students they um uh they tried and you
know Conrad wols I don't know if you
come across Conrad wolfram's criticism
of math education where he says you know
uh math education recapitulates history
for some reason like we you know we're
like we're going to learn numbers now
the Greeks in Pythagoras for some reason
uh and you know eventually get to
algebra and eventually calculus right
many students never get to calculus and
we don't learn any 20th century math in
high school let alone 21st century right
like we're missing huge swads why is
that really the most efficient way to do
it so Conrad you know uh obviously
wanting to sell some wol from products
but um you know he he he argues well in
the real world you and I do math on
computers right like we're not back in
the envelope calculations but that's not
where the hard stuff gets done right and
so um what you want is for kids to
understand what it means to take a
derivative what it means to what an
integral actually is and how it can be
used and maybe some stats and you know
like you want them to have mental models
and work alongside computers and you can
teach that before you like what's hard
about calculus is not the derivatives
and integrals it's the chain rule it's
the mechanics the quadratic you know
like it's those that are difficult
that's not what's important that was
built for world before you know my
middle school teacher was like make sure
you learn how to do mental math you're
not going to carry a calculator in your
pocket he didn't force the iPhone right
so we so they were able to trial that
and now they're triing this really
radical new uh education system uh where
they The Learning Happens at home right
where homework and school workor are
swapped basically like how can a teacher
teach to 20 to 30 kids of different
abilities they can't so the the the
lower end get left behind the upper end
are ignored right and so in order to do
that what happens is when you're at home
you get educational material you get
teachers and whatever you get this from
the best minds and then you come to
school to practice that you do the
homework where the teacher is not the
deliverer of knowledge they're the
facilitator helping you use the internet
and AI to practice your skills in a very
kind of practical real world focus and
you do that through radical
decentralization so the US works the
same way by the way you know Justice
brandise referred to each state as a
laboratory for democracy right Arizona
you want to try something go try it if
you fail you fail at an arizonan level
and if it works we bubble it up to the
top such a nadela converted Microsoft
from a monolith to a series of startups
using the same principle you know it's
like you're going to try different
things and we're going to Bubble it up
to Microsoft and it works and that they
invested in chat GPT and open AI right
great moves and the shares have been
have been soaring the Catholic Church
works this way by the way you know it's
like lasted for so long because they're
like well we got a central Authority but
you know Jesuits you go do your weird
thing and we're g to laugh at you for
most of it oh now we have a Jesuit Pope
because that worked out right you have
to have space to to to kind of explore
these possibilities to get out of that
trap so what do I why why am I talking
about all this because land value taxes
are something you can do in what I call
startup cities right like cities are the
place where we all live and countries
are increasingly untenable in some ways
like how do you get that but if you
Empower cities give them more autonomy
allow them to learn from one another
have a more startup ecosystem around
that this is a way out right this is the
engine of development that Hong Kong
represented for China this is why
Singapore is is at the top of the pza
tables you know it's it's how guango
works and now there's ACH startup cities
or Charter cities sometimes you know in
in Africa but this is a way past current
democracy and eventually maybe
programmable politics but I don't have
time to explain that it's in the book
it's in the book I think there's a lot
in the book and you know we've covered a
lot of it but I I do want to encourage
people to check out the book because it
it paints a much Fuller picture but
maybe we can sort of wind things up by
returning to something that we talked
about right at the beginning the the
children learning from the adults rather
than using their reasoning right that we
rely on our cultural transmission of
knowledge I want to feed that back into
what we were just talking about in terms
of inequality and and fairness and and
Innovation and things like that how much
of a problem is it that in the modern
era we're able to get that cultural
knowledge in a in a quite fine-tuned or
at least quite differentiated way even
within one culture right like if I in
your bus analogy if I am constantly told
that the buses come very rarely and
discriminate against me even if it's not
true that becomes a problem for how
Society
works yeah you know like you know people
talk about this is like the Walter
kronite problem you know like once upon
a time we all got our news well not me
I'm too young you know Walter con kite
you know was was on the Evening News um
and now like we all read different we
you know we read Breitbart and you know
and and Huffington Post and New York
Times we're all getting it from like
different places um so I I I think the
internet is interesting in that so I
argue that the internet is actually
creating we are not in the midst of a
fourth Industrial Revolution or fifth
Industrial Revolution we are in the
midst of a second Enlightenment okay one
driven not by coffee shops and pamphlets
and books but by tweets and you know and
shared articles on social media that
piss you off and they piss you off
because they expose you to ideas that
are not in your ingroup now alongside
that is a counterveiling force which is
that we are also able to assort in
smaller and smaller groups and those
groups can compete with one another in
other words the internet creates new
tribes right so you know um there's a
show here Little Britain and there's a
there's a character you know he's like
he I'm The Only Gay in the village you
know it's not true actually there's lots
of other gays in the village but um at
one SP of time you might have been like
if you had if you were a small minority
in a small village you were you did not
have a critical mass to do anything
right but the internet enables you to
find so you know I point to a couple of
examples so are you um are you into
carrying sand in your pocket Sean I am
not I never have done that well you know
like 30,000 people on like our you know
Reddit subreddit on pocket sand talk
about all the benefits of carrying sand
in their pockets but that's actually
kind of a niche interest unlike stapling
bread to trees like listeners go and
Google bread staple to a tree it is a
hobby held by around 300,000 people
right so yeah you get these different
groups but it's very hard it's very hard
to generalize whether that is Sil like
it's an empirical question whether we
are now in silos or actually exposed to
more information and both are true I
think what is actually the case is it's
not about the information it was never
about the information it was never about
misinformation it was about whom we
trust and what has happened is that our
trust in our institutions and to some
degree as a result of that in each other
has decreased and that is resulting in
selective access to that information and
greater assortment and the ultimate
issue here the ultimate level problem
needs to be solved and that is it's an
energy problem
actually sorry I you made a leap there
that I need to to figure out I mean I
agree that the trusted institutions has
waned um it seems to me like in some
ways that's an outcome of the same game
theoretic analysis of you know different
groups jockeying for space and things
like that uh and of course with the
caveat that some institutions are super
trustworthy so it's it's correct to not
trust them but so how do you bring it
back down to energy so sorry so you know
why why I say that it's you know it's
about the information is like there are
always people always calling for the end
of the world or saying that you know we
live in a racist Society or that you
know we live in a society where you're
getting screwed over or there's always
people there's always a bunch of people
saying everything but whom people listen
to depends on on circumstances right and
so what I'm arguing is there is a both a
perception in a reality and yes they can
like feed back on each other and the
reality is that truly our space of the
possible has indeed
Shrunk the amount of excess energy
available to each of us has actually
shrunk and you know round about the 19
you know the oil crisis 1980s 1970s you
know like it was around you know what
the happened in 1971 1973 this was
when it all happened the American dream
died around then because you suddenly
had a 50-50 probability of being better
off than your parents that has truly
happened right
and so that is fundamentally an issue of
excess energy which ultimately drives
GDP growth so like 50% roughly of GDP
growth is energy or 50% is about you
know Innovations and efficiency okay I I
do get it now so it comes back to this
uh shrinking distance between the
ceiling and the floor basically in our
society what what you know the amount
the amount that we have to all live in
together the scale of cooperation that
is that is incentivized and I will let
you um close the these sets of thoughts
with your optimistic spin on how we're
eventually going to work our way out of
this well you know so as I said you know
part one of the book lays it all out
lays out the science lays out the
problem but then part two is is exactly
about you know how do we like the
chapter titles are like how do we
reunite Humanity how do we create a new
forms of governance for the 21st century
how do we shatter that glass ceiling of
of inequality how do we trigger a
creative explosion that maybe gets us to
fusion and becoming the first generation
of a Galactic Civil ization how do we
improve the internet how do we as
individuals become brighter and because
like imagine you are the first
generation to have the periodic table
right we can stop doing Alchemy we start
doing some chemistry and there are
actual Solutions given the constraints
that we Face real life solutions that
are possible for tackling each of these
problems and that means that a brighter
future is possible if we so choose I
cannot close on any better sentence than
that so Michael Krishna thanks very much
for being on the mindscape podcast thank
you so much for having me Sean I loved
[Music]
it